[Applause]
wow
who knew okay tell me about the surprise
of it all okay so
first of all i can't believe what just
happened it was incredible thank you so
much i didn't know the crowd was going
to be excited um but i'm just you mean
you didn't know the crowd was going to
be excited
i was going to be excited
oh my god they were in it and um and
just i'm so thankful to jack because he
gave me this great opportunity to like
be a rapper like i've had a rap dream
for years is that what happened you
wanted to rap for a while i've been
wanting to rap forever
and everybody was like
everybody just wants to hear you sing or
don't do rap but i'm like i love rap i
love hip hop i love
all of that when you popped up the crowd
went crazy they were like look we're in
this jack but then they were like hold
on is that brandy i ran to the tv and i
was like oh my god that's brandi
i know i can't believe it i don't even
have the words you see i'm acting a mess
right now
how am i doing this in front of what
will we get when we get more rap from
you in the future
do you want to get more rap from me in
the future clearly the world wants more
i'm asking you can you look at the
camera because this is what i can use
for managing okay you said this is on
e-t okay
we need more rap from brandy she showed
you what she can do
let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
first place
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
how did this come together though real
quick okay how it came together is um
jack didn't really realize that my
brother and i were siblings
and on our on a radio show
he wrote shout out to ero he didn't tell
him that we were brother and sister and
then from there like it was it like
caused all this noise and i didn't catch
the noise until like five days later but
i was like oh my god so i sent out a
tweet and joking saying i would you know
i could i could take this guy on a rap
and i was like oh my god that's hip hop
i kind of have to back that up so i put
out a freestyle
and jack loved it and was like
let's do it on let's do it on the bc
awards
i couldn't believe that i was like this
was just me needing a reason to rap and
just fooling around and then
i'm here at the bt awards with jack
harlow it's really like serious it was
incredible and you look incredible you
look look y'all looking looking look at
brandy please look at that
that's that's a that's a grown woman's
mama and she looks amazing daughters in
the audience who's a she
got to see it yes and i think this is
her first bt awards
it was one to never forget brandy
[Music]